hey everybody it's me and I'm back from
the dead this is unbelievable my tour
solo is on pause because the Impractical
Jokers national tour has started the
arena tour tickets are on sale for the
first leg of it right now at impractical
jokerslive.com we're coming to Reading
Pennsylvania we're coming to uh Stony
Brook we're coming to Pittsburgh Camden
New Jersey Boston we're coming to
Charleston South Carolina Charlotte
North Carolina Waterloo New York uh
Washington DC Niagara Falls Newark
Wallingford Belmont Park we're playing
that UBS Arena and the Prudential arena
in Jersey Milwaukee Rosemont Seattle
Portland I mean guys Utah Denver
Arlington Austin Sugar Land Columbus
Cleveland Detroit Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City I'm getting tired Nashville
Indianapolis and St Louis that's just
what's announced right now and it's all
on sale right now we're revving up right
now the show's gonna be a blast we
haven't been out in years hope to see
you there in practicejokerslive.com hey
guess where I'm coming Phoenix January
26 to the 28th House of Comedy Phoenix
shows are already almost sold out my new
hour is wild I've been getting crazy on
stage so I think you want to see it
February 1st to 2nd Cleveland Ohio
hilarities Comedy Club early show sold
out we just got the late that's a
Wednesday Thursday midweek Chrissy why
not come have a midweek fun what else is
there to do in Cleveland February 16th
to the 17th Stanford Connecticut there's
a brand new club there called New York
comedy club in Stamford Connecticut and
my manager the Italian woman owns it so
I got roped into doing it so it's going
to be fun I'm probably gonna do every
show drunk or high so you're going to
want to buy tickets to that and get your
phones out February 22nd Vancouver
British Columbia first time ever in
Vancouver movie I'm opening up the JFL
Just for Laughs Comedy Festival at the
Vogue theater low ticket count there um
and then I believe
um we are adding we have added uh
February 20
um February 24th in Napa February 25th
in San Jose and February 26 in
Sacramento California um I believe those
are the dates but correct me if I'm
wrong but I am coming in that week that
last weekend in February to uh the
second to last weekend no I guess it is
the last week in February yeah last week
in February to San Jose Napa and
Sacramento christiecomedy.com for taking
wikis and then Florida at the end of
March and Austin in April and buffalo in
May I love you I love [ __ ]
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe
[Music]
since last hey babe oh hey babe how you
doing good I have a guests on guests yes
because we weren't because Sal if there
was a few weeks where he was dead like
he actually died I died when we brought
him back to life and that's why I want
to have you come in just in case because
uh if Sal died again I want to have I
want to have you in here what about Joe
oh Joe's here Joe
fifth podcast of today
well Joe yeah
so I want to do is yeah go eat dinner
with you guys I gotta eat before 5 30
because it doesn't fit my fasting window
if I eat after it girl's gotta eat your
fighter stands at 5 30. yeah that's what
I've been doing yes yesterday that's the
thing right yesterday like what I
started eating today at 12 I did a 22
hour fast yesterday because it was just
so bad after the holidays
what's so bad what do you mean so bad
what is so bad I overeat the way I know
what are you eating what are you eating
okay so so new uh uh New Year's Day okay
so you were up at the castle Yeah I had
at oheka Castle New Year's Day on New
Year's Eve is on New Year's Day
technically it was two o'clock in the
morning that's how I started okay New
Year's Day you know drinking eating all
New Year's Eve you know pies cookies but
then I had from McDonald's Uber Eats uh
two Big Macs a filet of fish two things
of french fries and a McFlurry that's
one order that's one order that's just
for you because I benched the way
honestly Joe I know this we we talked
about this on Whiskey Ginger but the way
that you say like when you drink and you
want to have fun that's the way I get
with eating and that's what I have to
get under control yeah and say I can't
[ __ ] do that you've told me you've
told me stories of like eating an entire
large pizza in 10 minutes yeah I guess
I've done that dude so my like Mike hen
dude how do you say so thick when I eat
I inhale food when I eat anyway it's
like a habit of my whole my whole family
eats so fat but then what do you do to
balance that because you've never been
heavy as long as I throw up yeah
told us that he's bulimic that He makes
himself puke that I believe it's not bad
he always smells no giveaway and he's
got no teeth got no enamel on the front
no no no because he's eating yamakas all
day
well you know those candles they got to
eat each one yeah that's what it is yeah
no but how do you say so thin uh because
I because when I do that it's few and
far between and I don't eat [ __ ] I just
don't eat [ __ ] during the day but it's
your regular day like this morning yeah
let's take me through a regular day I
try to wake up yesterday do yesterday
well we'll be traveling this is travel
is tough okay but at home yeah tell me
to wake up and I try to either go like
stretch or I do stretch every day
because when I broke my back I know that
sounds lame but broken he did crunch me
I go my legs don't go over my head and
then yeah you know then I was already
there I was like go for it Daddy yeah
um I'll either try to exercise in some
way either run or go lift and you fast
you not eat till like noon no no it's
funny I'll eat in the morning if my body
says I'm hungry if I'm not hunger in the
first wake up I won't eat I'll eat after
I work out I'm not one of these people
that's like Anna if I'm hungry I'll eat
and wait and then what will you eat what
are you eating sometimes overnight oats
in Granola one of my favorite things is
uh I love overnight oats yeah but but
but for the most part breakfast is my
favorite meal I love
breakfast but my breakfast are like
overnight oats versus oatmeal which was
a joke Ted Alexandro had which was very
funny well overnight oats is chia seeds
it's it's chia pudding right cheese
oatmeal I thought no no no no no oats
are oatmeal overnight oats is chia
pudding no I thought overnight oats
oatmeal that you just put in the fridge
yeah yeah so like I'll make overnight
oats oats yes I'll make I'll take
Quakers Chia I have chia pudding pudding
yeah pudding
I've had them both yeah yeah you make it
with almond milk and it's like a good
yeah in the morning you want a little
secret I found that whole cinnamon mush
it's cold
nice it's a 200 calories
I love yogurt in the morning and then
I'm not doing egg bacon egg and cheese
here's the thing I like bacon I love
eggs I just don't need the roll every
day so I just don't eat it like that
anymore I'll just do scrambled eggs and
bake I'll do some meat next but then
will you eat bread at some point during
the day you have like a light lunch like
that usually don't eat that much bread
you don't just don't need it I mean I
look I love it but I just every time I
think about it I go like what I don't
need a [ __ ] I don't need the sandwich
so I think sandwich is a good thing my
body took a turn where eggs and all that
[ __ ] in the morning just started really
disagreeing with me like it's so greasy
it started getting a stomach ache and
yeah if I eat anything in the morning I
try to keep it to like fruit or whatever
I'd rather have that because you just
eaten overnight oats or Chia no no or or
eggs and like eggs in a meat but we have
avocado never never Bowl this year
cereal to me is a late night come home
from the clubs I'm tired well if you eat
a bowl of cereal I mean you're just
you're eating sugar I mean it's all it's
all sugar we have those healthy [ __ ]
cereal magic spoon
[Music]
no no I just mean like
just Cheerios is you know what I mean
just yeah yeah yeah
I talked to lunch now go do lunch yeah
what do you do for lunch
sometimes I skip lunch
whoa like because sometimes I'll have a
bunch of Japanese well I have such a big
meal in the morning right that I won't
need lunch and I'll have a couple of
coffees and that usually what's the big
meal you just said you might have some
some Chia no if I have granola and then
I do we do apples in a pan with yogurt
I'm all that stuff and what does that
mean you put okay so is it literally
just put a little bit of brown sugar in
there caramelize some apples in a pan
put them in there with granola and a big
huge scoop of peanut butter with yogurt
that's a healthy snack take a walk it's
delicious that's healthy but it's the
same deceivingly also loaded with fat
and and calories but if you're if you're
exercising at all you're using those to
your advantage fat and calories are not
bad everyone's like fat they're not bad
if you're using them they're not bad
right right if you're eating fats and
not doing anything particularly
saturated fats well then yeah we have a
big dinner usually or you go live you're
a light eater no I I like a good sized
dinner like you'll you'll go crazy at
dinner steaks chickens anything any
other burger fries I eat almost
exclusively at home this is out of my
home not on the road big proteins so
like chickens or steaks or Meats fish
whatever and then three or four sides of
like vegetables mac and cheese you'll
get mac and cheese no that you won't get
the fat I get it once in a while but I
don't get that's not like what I'm gonna
have just potatoes and vegetables on the
side you want a nice side you probably
don't think of but usually more
vegetables than anything else a salad
vegetables meat and a fish of some kind
and then maybe one little naughty boy
thing wait you'll go like one fish
together eat or fish okay okay what's
the normal
a little naughty boy dessert like what
yeah hold a little hold to come
a little hold the cone okay hold the
cone a little A Little Couple come
but you don't have dessert every day you
have it once a week maybe uh two two to
three times I have dessert like once a
day
see I just I usually have like after I
just it even if it's just having a
cookie I just there's something to
having a sweet sweet at my head no so
what I've been usually that's what I
want yeah
my daughter my old Delilah is on me now
she's got to think she's like only can
only have sweets on Saturday and she's
on me like this morning when she left
for school she's like no sweets today
but Saturday this is the difference you
have kids we don't have kids there is no
sweets at my house we don't just buy
yeah that's all in my house yeah for
kids we there's no kids if it's in the
house I'm done yeah
probably sleep on a nice dinner side or
launcher let me guess cremini mushrooms
no but that is good I was gonna say
Pharaoh Pharaoh here's my name
yeah where's it from where is from I
don't know yeah Egypt I don't know
that's why I don't trust it I don't know
where it's from I know it's back that's
a smart joke where's Pharaoh from yeah I
didn't get it really give it he didn't
give it anything
wait when you said pharaohs from Egypt
you weren't joking what do you mean stop
it a pharaoh yeah a pharaoh like a king
yeah I said it's for me I said that's a
smarter joke than it than it got oh my
joke I think you're saying because
where's you
because I thought it was too easy it was
too easy yeah
[Laughter]
I'll go all day on King Tut I thought it
was pretty fair pretty quick I
appreciate that it's very good yeah
that's good yeah thank you thank you I
love power they call me Farrell Fawcett
one more get one more okay
um
what's up you want to hear a story about
pheromones I'm Jay Pharoah I want to hit
two I want I was looking for music for
my special which is out right now
cheeseburger on Netflix available right
now no [ __ ] title January 10th I don't
know when this comes out oh right right
he named it special after something he
never eats cheeseburger yeah cheese
burger like from that comic in the 80s
right it was hamburger but I'll say this
all right I'll give you a fair amount
story because you want to know real fast
I really like the song from Pharaoh
monster that I used on tour called Simon
Says sure sure [ __ ] up you know he
doesn't know that stuff Simon Says get
the [ __ ] up throw you he doesn't he's
watching I swear girls rub on your
titties you [ __ ] I said it rub on
your titties
very cool that I have that ability it's
very cool and then I said I know you
know him is there a way that you can
connect him with our post-producer
because I did the special all on my own
with my production guys and with 800
pound actually with Schuler who's the
man who did Ari shaffir's and
I said I have only so much money for
music but I'll pay for it out of my
pocket and Premiere got back to me in
like five seconds which one of the
coolest [ __ ] dudes of all time and
also mind-boggling as a kid that I'm
texting with I know a hero of mine I
know it means nothing to some people but
he's the greatest of all time uh yeah
well yeah yeah anyway and I said uh you
know you know what is what would this
cost or whatever and Pharaoh got back to
him Pharaoh man said
um that original
is from Godzilla one and it's Warner
Brothers or whoever owned the rights to
that they've been in a forever legal
battle because that was never cleared 20
years ago and so he has the mechanics of
the song They're legally his but can't
license it out to anybody yeah wow he's
like they will sue you like Warners or I
don't remember who who I think won her
music yeah and he was like they'll sue
you so he's like all my love I
appreciate it but shout out to Gia
Premier for helping me out and then he
helped me get rjd2
has an original song on my special it's
very cool which I thought was [ __ ] So
Dope amazing because the DJ Premiere but
but Pharaoh I guess was saying he was
like I wish I could help but good no
[ __ ] that's very cool but I would
love to get sued from Warner Music would
have been kind of tight just amazing
I want to get us a good song for the
special too you never have to pay for it
or ask for a favor
I know some of those guys or this is do
you know the budos band my boys from
Staten Island I'm just trying to think
you know why recently I don't know if
you would know who this is but you know
Prince Paul yeah I love Prince Paul
Prince Paul recently befriended him he's
a wonderful man Prince Paul is your
buddy yes so good and he asked me to be
on uh do skits on his new album and I
was like I can't believe it and then he
said uh how much do you want and I said
all of it I mean don't be don't be
ridiculous like 500 Grand I'll do it for
it I'll do it it's an honor to do it and
then he gave me the assignment and then
I was like how long do I have and he
said two weeks I was like perfect
because there's a lot of riffing and
writing and stuff and then he's like the
next day he's like I need it actually by
tomorrow morning I just got word from
and I was on tour and I chose I'm not
able to get it I felt so bad but he
brought his family out and he came to my
show in Atlanta shout out Prince Paul
but the moral of the story is you let
Prince Paul down yes that's exactly
right you should if Paula Abdul do
something on your album oh yeah that'd
be cool imagine I wasn't as good as the
Pharaoh stuff he's a fan of Paul Abdul
uh Paul Abdul is a fan of his too and he
was in his movie friends with Paul Abdul
oh I got a story but I uh please do it
Apollo Abdul story
yeah it's fine well okay Paul Abdul came
to The Comedy Store okay wait is this
another family joke let me know where
this is gonna go
yeah um is it is it is it not a good
look hold on just look up this guy real
fast look up Guam Guam like the country
look up Guam Comedy Store
you wouldn't believe this or [ __ ] this
is such a inside baseball that's that's
him go images and see that's him but go
images because you might be able to see
he's bald but he has a ponytail he's a
rat tail oh you haven't seen this guy
before yeah he works the door he's a
store he's a store guy yeah I've seen
this guy Juan Felix
Game of Thrones yeah as fast as I can
about a nice purple picture this
[ __ ] Apollo Doo showed up to The
Comedy Store blacked out and loved him
because he was security helping her get
to a seat and she was all over him she
was like obsessed and kept rubbing his
head and kissing his forehead I love it
and at some point at the end of the
night gives him her phone number and
starts kissing Guam in the parking lot
you can't I don't know who the guy is in
New York that is I don't know who the
New York guy is but in La it was
magically hilarious all right guys it's
Steve fabrican outside Steve
she gave him the number and she was
making out with him and I thought one
day thing or whatever one she was drunk
with friends having a good time yeah oh
no dude they were texting for days on
end afterwards she's cool like that she
is cool like that very down to earth
very accessible Abdul's out there
turning it up I'm talking about quitting
drinking yeah come on
shave your hand and just put a ponytail
out there Juan Felix
um and that's our boy Rick Ingram down
there on the left who opens up for uh
Chappelle and opens up for rock now oh
that's wild man I'm so proud of that guy
yeah he was a comedy store guy for years
and then finally somebody gave him some
recognition and rock I think saw him
loved him and then he only does crowd
work Rick Ingram only does crowd work
100 exclusive well I mean you know I
don't know his art but you know what I
mean like I can't speak on what is but
his his skill set is crowd working and
they have a camera because they play
huge stadiums or whatever him yeah
that's Rick okay and they they have a
camera like you if you go on their
Instagrams he's on all these pictures
with them playing Arenas so now the
camera follow him with the front row to
show the people right so that everyone
else in the arena he must annihilate you
have no [ __ ] idea he must I'm not
kidding he is the way that like East
Coast guys like uh big J crowd work you
know right yeah that he he this guy's a
[ __ ] murderer yeah that's a good
analogy the way that people like that
what no am I wrong yeah
making fun of I was making fun of the
needless analogy when you're like guys
you know crowd work like like let's see
in the way that [ __ ] big J does in
East Coast terms you know you've seen
maybe a big one well here's why I
verified it because everybody [ __ ]
online is putting up crab Rook reels now
so it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] you think that
about Jay
clip it clip it that's a nice try
alcoholic but here's the deal you don't
burn
what he thinks
actually premiere's a fan of Jace
he really is they're friendly from do
you like Joe DeRosa he doesn't know who
I am I know that's why I'm gonna ask him
he's he's my favorite producer
turning over in his grave Premiere is my
favorite producer of all time I think
he's the greatest of all time next to
doctor it's it's it's Premiere now what
do you think about Pharrell
you know he's highly regarded as like
one of the topic Pharrell is tremendous
but he's not anywhere near my favorite
hip-hop producer of all time no I know
it's an opinion I know people look I'm a
DJ Premier guy but that's only because
the way I grew up with it I hear a
Premiere beat first of all you can spot
a premier beef yeah from a mile away
yeah hear it uh and and nothing excites
me more than the DJ Premiere beats every
single beat he just he produces for all
the right people he's the best he's the
greatest that's ever he is the greatest
he's the greatest you know I would say
rivaled only by Dr Dre no I think Dr Dre
is not even closer DJ Premiere in my
opinion what about Funk Master Flex CJ
Dr Dre did more more stuff
doesn't produce really I don't think
he's a producer I don't think I know
what that is if you look at Dre's
catalog yeah incredible
wa stuff alone yeah the production value
of it you know what I mean so it was
like Diplo a producer all right taught a
guy had a rap like huh Eazy-E couldn't
rap you never show you never know about
that yeah I know the police Brothers
I know the whole story this is good for
the show yeah I don't know you guys are
doing that and I'm talking to him not
even with the mic yeah I don't know what
a music producer does I don't know I
don't know anything about that I don't
know in hip-hop to produce it usually
makes the Beats that's what it means who
produces like uh Jay-Z's music or Kanye
West music
a lot of Jay-Z's music but then who
produces for Kanye Kanye Kanye he just
does the guy who does everything
he's done a little bit too much lately
Kanye's Talent is off the chain which is
why his success was off the chain Kanye
is one of the greatest ones
was allowed to progress to the place
he's one of the greatest musical
entities in the history of human life in
my opinion right he's he's done he is a
brilliant musician and rapper and he's
the new he's the rapper went he went
missing he's been missing you don't know
about this he's the new Richard Wagner
for days he's still but he's still
missing yeah and is it like are they do
they feel the people around me oh he's
just off he wants somebody's got to know
where he won't be off the ground or is
there fear have you seen his swastika
merch he has swastika merch no he
doesn't show it can you swascar merch on
sale no no he doesn't yes he does no he
does not I swear to God
clipping him showing up and I'm not
gonna believe you there sure is a lot of
Kanye West inspired Nazi Merch online
baby he's got some swash merch out there
did you see him showing up at the
Fashion Show on Instagram no oh yeah
yeah white lives matter no no no like
the other day he showed up in a Runway
thing and the clothing line was like oh
yeah that's Kanye wearing our stuff it's
like you guys are this desperate anyway
his [ __ ] lip was bleeding he had a
mouth guard in like a boxing mouth guard
well he broke a straw and when he sat
down somebody net somebody next to him
said something and he literally goes
like this he goes
and like he he were like dude this guy I
hope he's okay like he's he's off the
reservation I mean that's what happens
with the booster
which one is it I know
is that what you mean
possibly like in danger or endangered
yeah I think so yeah or it's not just
like oh he just he did he's tiny doing
Kanye he's probably off in a remote I
think people are scared that he's gone
he is but it's got a Balenciaga
mouthpiece it said he is out of his mind
like like that's why it bothers me Kanye
West's new song about DJ DJ Khaled I
think it is yeah well I get it yeah I
get it I get it if you met his kid it's
it's yeah I get it yeah I get it really
no unbearable no idea I think this is
Kanye
doing a another bit I think he's gone
missing doing a bit uh dude yes 100
there's a part of me that believes that
no he's that was that was that pimps at
it they make him Hitler yeah I kind of
don't believe it was actually him on
Alex Jones personally but really that's
insane it didn't really sound like him
yes it did I didn't think it did it's
not exactly like him so nothing like him
you don't know so nothing when I cook
yeah what's what does CJ from here what
he thinks what
foreign
against lgbtq people that's what it says
what do you say about them
I'll call you him
I never call you they
here's my main question about the about
the Alex Jones appearance why did he
cover his face like that the whole time
because he's talking about it
so we're talking about it you're bad at
marketing he's memorable he's there's
definitely a little bit of a Tony
Clifton thing with all this but I don't
know he's [ __ ] up man I I do think you
think Kanye West is Bob zamuta yes Bob
zimood is Kanye West yeah that's the
problem he's
how is that not that is so funny wait
what he's saying Netanyahu Netanyahu oh
my God the Israeli Prime Minister is
don't make another DJ Premiere joke
again now if you don't know that's what
he's saying there that's very funny no
he didn't I think that was oh it was
that was photos it was Photoshop oh
[Music]
you know it does have nice and
riboflavin uh where all the drinks don't
yes yeah that is true you remember those
commercials not a chocolate milk the
chocolate drink yeah my kids love you
really I have out of you in 20 years but
kids will need the kids that get that
you can find them
commercials yeah the riboflavin and they
go yeah
niacin yeah well they didn't say like
that I think it's just close though
yeah tell me what's up me thinks yeah
it's a bit
I think he thinks it's some great grand
insane bit I think he thinks that but I
think that's being fueled by a yes yes
yes I'm not saying it hasn't gone too
far and I'm not saying it's not insane
I'm saying I think he thought he was
going to do a a an insane bit and it was
going to be performance art for him I
think he thought I can turn myself into
the most hated man in the world watch
watch me [ __ ] do it and everybody
will know the guy was I I keep citing
this and it's like it's like it just
kills me it's like
I I've been saying he's an [ __ ] for
so [ __ ] long now I mean he he was six
years ago was screaming I am Shakespeare
in public yeah and everybody was like
you go Kanye and it's like
he's an [ __ ] like he's a f he's off
his [ __ ] Rocker Man well he went
he could be Shakespeare though he could
be like how could he not be he's he's as
close as we're gonna get yeah
I'm not saying because Shakespeare's so
good I'm just saying the arrogance of it
and you're screaming it in a room and
everybody's going yeah but part of
hip-hop culture is what that he called
you oh yeah did you hear that that he
called that he texted Shane Gillis what
did he have his number well it's just
who now Shane told the story but he I
mean he texted Shane out of nowhere and
wanted him to do like a sketch or
something
see I think he wants to be a comedian he
thinks this is a perform I'm telling you
dude he's talking to comedians he's he
is he he [ __ ] went to Anthony
Jeselnik's show the week before he did
this do you know the story Justin to
talk he's been quoting Owen Benjamin I
think he even said something about Tim
dude he went to [ __ ] Jeselnik's show
in like Oxnard or some [ __ ] Anthony
talks about it on his podcast and was
like
I mean bad time to learn a new fan you
know like right how the [ __ ] did this
all he I'm a that's what I'm saying
that's too far how does jesel in the
candle that he didn't even know he's in
the crowd he knew after the fact someone
was like Kanye West came there he's like
Kanye West came back Kelly Ryan text uh
Liz as we're on the way home and says
holy [ __ ] she goes the sound guy told me
that uh Kanye was here on Friday and I'm
like I don't believe you and then he
goes on a podcast yeah I think it's a
Lex Friedman podcast which I've never
heard of I listened in like six and a
half minutes in I see I see this clip I
was in Oxnard last night to see Anthony
jeselnick I'm doing interviews and I'm
thinking I'm funny and his opening joke
was so high level I realized that I
wasn't funny I realized that this dude
is a professional everybody
except Adidas and then he does this
interview where he gives me my flowers
and Adidas was like that's too much you
can't say the anti-semitic stuff we're
Adidas we can handle it we're old school
German
but if you've been dressing like his
flowers it would be like if someone was
like anything hey Greg someone just uh
called you what do you mean like give
him his props props yeah it's like it's
like it's like I love Jessica by the way
but but I just don't like that term yeah
I know I'm gonna tell him he said that
Connie was like wow a misdirect joke I
never thought I know you know what's so
nuts though is that
I'm telling you this to me was partial
proof that this dude wants to be a comic
and thinks [ __ ] if I do some elaborate
insane so so again we're back to Bob's
mood you know what it is yeah
but I'm saying he saw T.I do it
TI led by example he could be doing an
Andy Kaufman I think but this is this is
levels above but but my point is
Buddha's whole thing was literally what
you said right yes literally you said
becoming the most hated man in the world
that was what Andy Kaufman's gag was
with the wrestling women I know but
there was there was there was a there
was an irony to it that was really
intelligent that when he was like when
he was doing this like no woman can beat
me it was joking about the idea of a guy
saying women can't beat men that was
sure he's subversive right this is not
subversive he's doing this thinking I
can put together I know what you're
saying Joe I'm just saying this is him
thinking I'm gonna be the greatest
comedian alive I can fool the world in
my opinion I think he thinks right we're
saying the same thing though no Andy did
it with Bob that was more like
I think that was inside no no no hold on
hold on oh the only difference to what
we're saying is you're saying Andy
Kaufman was good at it and Bob's I mean
and uh Kanye West isn't that's the only
difference no actually Kanye turned out
to be really good at it but they were
disappearing when he was doing that
whole women thing dude he was losing
fans and [ __ ] people were like dude
you're going too far this is [ __ ] up I
know but his his Fame was also relative
he wasn't he wasn't that famous this guy
is a global phenomenon prior to trying a
bit like this
but I think they're two different things
I think what you're saying is like Andy
did it as a piece of like art I think
this guy thinks it is proof that he is
the greatest comedian right look if he's
doing it or not doing it my point is
this I would not be surprised if after
seeing him say those things he is trying
to do some Andy kaufman-esque sure
whatever okay we're saying because
because he don't forget this is the guy
that wears the light White lives matter
shirt uh he's the guy that you can buy
right now at Chrissy chaos Christian
comedy.com remember when he wore
hospital scrubs and said this is like
the new whatever
he does a lot of [ __ ] where he's like
what about the song that said Scoopy
poop scoopity poop I love that
Scooby-Doo I know it was good but my
good song that I thought he said I'm
going to put out a song called scoopity
poop and people are gonna dance to it
and buy it and I'm gonna prove to you
that I could do whatever the [ __ ] I want
I could put out what
vessey sneakers the rubber shoes that we
all love they literally are waterproof
non-water resistant they're awesome I
love messy shoes they're the only
rubbers I wear this shoes are game
changers okay they make shoes that
literally your feet never get wet
they're waterproof
um and the vessi cloud burst that's the
best shoe to have in the winter it's got
the rubber winter boot built into a
sneaker I mean that's all I've been
looking for is how do I get a sneaker
boot vessi has it and it's waterproof
it's got a super soft knit material that
keeps your feet warm in the cold but
cool in the warmer months and it doesn't
feel like it should be waterproof but
baby it is I've had my kids pour their
apple juice in them and my feet still
stay dry
now right now we're going to give you
listen you know here at hey babe we're
always giving you offers so vessey
they're my go to Shoes by the door and
all you gotta do right now if you want
to get your a nice discount on a pair of
Vesti shoes go to vesi.com that's
v-e-s-s-i.com slash hey babe 15 off your
entire order vessi.com hey babe 15 off
your entire order at vesti.com it's
awesome go get em hellofresh America's
number one meal kit and hey babe we talk
about it every week because we love it
so much I use it Sal uses it we cook
with it with our families it is awesome
and it is 25 cheaper than takeout it's
they got they got smart they got smart
recipes carb smart recipes high protein
they got this thing which I love
especially for football season homegate
it's like
um uh an assortment of snacks appetizers
and shareable sweets available at the
hello Fresh Market and you can treat
your friends to baby back ribs chocolate
chip brownies and everything between
that's awesome that Home gate thing uh I
think I'm getting that I hope hopefully
I'm getting that hellofresh I want the
Home gate um if not I'll just buy it I
don't care because guess what
me and Tyler talk about this every week
we don't understand how this company
even makes money because they give away
so much stuff for free listen to this
deal if you go to hellofresh.com hey
babe21 and use the code hey babe21
you're going to get 21 free meals plus
free shipping do you understand what I
just said hellofresh.com hey babe21 use
the code hey babe21 21 free meals plus
free shipping hellofresh America's
number one meal kit
DraftKings baby football season anytime
it's Sports which is 12 months a year
DraftKings is my go-to of course the NFL
playoff action is continuing Goji men
we're one step closer to the Super Bowl
One Step Closer to Super Bowl 57 and for
the NFL divisional round which is this
weekend
check out DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NFL new customers can bet just five
dollars and get 200 in free bets
instantly okay five dollars 200 in free
bets instantly all you have to do is
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use code hey babe new customers can
bet five dollars on the NFL division
around and get 200 and free bets
instantly only at DraftKings Sportsbook
with code hey babe minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply see show
notes for yeah yeah that's why he did
that because he wanted the thing to do
he's still he still made it back he's
still called it
like I never even heard of this genius
genius he didn't just put the beat out
over a verse yeah he literally put the
beat out over repeating scoopity poop I
think we're saying the same thing too I
understand what you're saying I'm just I
just know that like look and this is
Kanye doing Kirby enthusiasm stuff in a
mask from 15 years ago so this is what
he thinks is funny Andrew's right this
is just what he thinks I think he thinks
these are bits that's why I'm saying him
wearing the mask on Alex Jones is
something or he's not even behind the
mask on Alex Jones could be something I
yeah I know what you're saying yeah yeah
I get it yeah yeah it's Okay We're Not
Gonna it's not gonna get to like it's
not gonna become taste buds
let me ask you this let me ask you this
you're sober right I forgot I forgot
I know I thought we were on his show
again let's let if you're sober right
let's say You're Sober 10 years right
fully sober from everything and then
accidentally accidentally you suck a
dick you suck a dick no accidentally you
eat um a chocolate edible right you eat
it was just in your fridge and you
accidentally ate this chocolate edible
did you break your sobriety and do you
have to go all the way back to square no
no you don't think so no if you were
fooled into something fooled because
I've had friends who've said that
they've accidentally had something with
alcohol in it and they didn't know and
it doesn't change their sobriety no they
they because that you only break your
sobriety if you fall off the wagon you
choose to do it you have to oh it has to
be a choice
if you got let's say you got dosed and
the the high was so strong that you were
like [ __ ] it yeah and then and then you
it goes into a two-week binge well yeah
that's a different story but yeah
because because now my friend who this
happened to he's like I now that I got
High I just I want to start drinking
again oh and that's bad but he hasn't
but he's like I just want to yeah but
that's not a break of sobriety that's
just uh oh he's convinced himself when
they get like Percocets because they
have an operation or something and they
go home that's always a tough thing for
people to fall over that you have to
like take medication for like a surgery
or something yeah one of my cousins is
allergic to penicillin that's it dude
you get an infection you're just screwed
you can't be allergic to penicillin is
there's no alternative for him they are
but they don't work as well they suck
they're pretty weak the the other ones
they absolutely I do want to suck I do
want to give a shout out real fast to
Nick Cannon for his 12th baby Nick
congrats you just got the does yeah he
said my body my choice I support you on
that supporter go ahead Nick I support
you Nick he's getting a vasectomy he's
not he's saying my body my choice he
scoffs out he's not doing it he would
never
12. if you could kill one first who
would you kill first Andy Cohen or
Anderson Cooper
who would you kill first Sal
mon pass those questions off to someone
else
um yeah I'm saying I'm not saying
it's like you know who would you rather
have
been on I've
let's do [ __ ] Mary kill Anderson Cooper
Nick Cannon and this will make it even
more powerful okay well I've I've I've
been on what's Watch What Happens Live
Andy's show okay I've never met the
other two guys uh so I guess that means
nothing
I think I was the bartender
this is an easy one I think we bought I
bartend and I watch what happens I would
marry you guys we do that yeah we do
that Mary Anderson Cooper absolutely
you're married he seems like yeah he
seems like someone might settle down you
marry Coop you [ __ ] Nick Cannon nope you
don't [ __ ] Nick candy don't think he's
got a pipe you don't think he's got that
you don't think yeah but actually it's a
party I don't want the pipe actually
Andy Cohen's annoying to have sex with
didn't tell him Chris yeah he's good
yeah what's it all about him he just
talked about you he's from St Louis he
just talked to me about the Cardinals
I'm like just shut up I'm not looking to
get pregnant with Canon's kid right you
know what I'm saying okay well make him
pull out
leave it do that Nikki leave it in all
right I mean how is how can you have
FaceTime the necessary face time with a
dozen children and that kind of schedule
he's like literally on FaceTime texting
that's the only way yeah
um yeah I don't think I think you have
two daughters you have an assistant and
you have you're busy with work he's next
level he's on like 15 shows right right
right and he has he has six 600 more
kids than you yes yeah but he has the
financial ability to continuously get on
a jet and go home
I think what his what he feels I think
is and this is just one way to do this
is he feels his part of him being alive
and a human and his experience here on
Earth is to spread his seed procreate to
the mother to kind of raise the child
and do that and he'll be there
financially support but he knows that he
cannot give the time and energy
obviously he's worked out a deal because
they don't get it's there's plenty and
nobody's mad at him none of his baby
mamas are mad at him how many moms is it
I think it was like any of them Mariah's
Mariah's got something I didn't know
where I had two
beautiful kids yeah they're all good
looking he's a good looking guy
and every every woman he's with is good
looking yeah yeah
he's just pumping out good looking
people yeah he's making beautiful people
for the future yeah right so what are we
mad at do you know like what I would
like to see
it's good what I would like to see from
Nick Cannon if I'm just being honest is
a little diversity in his baby mamas
yeah I don't see enough diversity
what about someone like that what about
Ukraine
do you stand with you cranes yes or no I
say stay black Nick do what you're doing
[ __ ] those white people that's it trash
really really yeah wow
my sister got married on uh Halloween
and uh they got made up like that I
think it's funny so you don't like his
sister then you don't like the movie
Coco Coco was a great book so it's great
that's the best one artwork aesthetic I
don't care for it what's your favorite
artwork it's static I don't know to be
honest to have it I don't even know if
it's my least favorite I'm just not a
big fan this guy's a uh contrarian yeah
I just don't I'm not into it it's like
not scary skeletons I don't like it I
like a scary skeleton
by the way speaking is scary you know
what the two scariest movies of all
timers and I've watched them both this
weekend smile and and white chicks and
white chicks yes smile and hereditary
was scary I watch them both of my kids
it was scary
my daughter that's what she likes to
watch just tell me if I should watch
smile was it good yeah
very scary I heard it was good the other
night and my lady just she just won't
watch it she's like terrified stuff like
this is now it's it's you and you
thought it was stupid it's it's it's
it's no no smile was great I thought
smile was was a great solid heart it's
worth a watch yes yes hereditary has a
few scares so could you watch smile Joe
could you could you watch smile alone in
a house by yourself with the lights off
that's right
in them it's by myself it doesn't freak
you out not not literally not even a
tiny bit see like I watched smile I
could go to sleep to that movie if it
wasn't for the loud noises right I know
what you mean because it's it's a
toss-up for me it's something's really
getting out of my skin or not sometimes
you ever on the road in the hotel and
like sometimes I will leave the TV on I
always do that because I need a little
light in there I get a little spook
turning it pitch black I can't I always
see a figure yeah yes smile with smile
and the same as hereditary but more with
smile we watched that movie with my
family I wouldn't let my daughter
watching my kitchen upstairs uh upstairs
the way he lives Delilah my daughter
asked for water two nights in a row
dying of thirst I would not go down to
the kitchen and get her because I was
terrified I was gonna see this
order like wanted you to come get
Jasmine have to go do it to put down our
crying one-year-old get her to sleep and
then I made my daughter wait for water
because I was paralyzed with fear
getting out of that damn bed
that's what I said I said Delilah I can
put your mouth over the sink I'm not
going down the stairs she was like I
need to drink it out of a cup I was like
well then tell the girl from smile
though
it feels scary for me it freaks me what
happens is is when I watch a movie like
this it becomes a reality to me and I
start to see and feel these people Kanye
dude
this podcast have you ever seen it
follows oh yeah what's it follows that's
a good horror movie that's a good thing
like it follows
but it's going to scare you too but what
but I'm not scared of like demons and
ghoul like that's not that what do you
say what the [ __ ] was smile that was
smile was a demon but it's because it's
like I was getting the impression it
follows is very much like smart ready to
have sex with somebody and then this
thing starts
huh spoilers no that's like the that's
kind of common now okay yeah about smile
no no it follows oh it follows I'm
saying smile is simple why smile scared
me is because there are demons it's you
know demonic but you know that from the
from this but what scared me about it is
that a lot of people were saying like
this is what like someone with
schizophrenia might see and feel like so
it kind of made me feel like these
people were saying like you know like
you deal with a schizophrenic person
they're like it's right there that
there's nothing there but they're
paralyzed with right that's what what
that felt like it felt realistic it felt
like it could be real right when it's a
demon and a [ __ ] you know
at the end of smile I was like all right
this is stupid like when it gets to this
face I'm like I don't want to look the
beginning of it when it's just like
literally uh yeah yeah that it's creepy
because that's what you just see you're
a [ __ ] dude dude you are a [ __ ] you're
crying about quitting drinking
well we all have different types of
demons
no I know how much longer does this go
dude is this done yet yeah dude we
didn't do we do well we didn't do plugs
anyway did you see the new Nicolas Cage
movie no you know what bearable weight
of massive time you wanted to see it it
is a grand slam really laugh out loud
unbelievable he's at the top of his game
and so is Pedro Pascal I watch it two
times
they hire him because they hire he goes
this guy's house yeah I started it he
didn't like it I think I just got turned
well I don't know but I think it was
something I don't know it didn't click
with me really I'll try it again okay my
two film recommendations have been solid
this year it's uh everything everywhere
all at once just watch it two nights ago
one of the best movies I've ever seen in
my entire life what's that one I gotta
finish it everything everywhere all at
once is incredible okay say something I
started to watch it twice and both times
about Midway I stopped watching it yeah
it's not like I'm stopping it but like I
can't I got overwhelmed this like I kind
of like interest got pulled away it's a
lot but also uh I think one of the best
comedies I've seen this year is triangle
of sadness oh man I heard that's awesome
have you seen it no dude look up
triangle of sadness pimpy it's
incredible there was a movie uh called
Force Major that he did the same
director we tried to do it in America it
bombed really bad
um this thing is so funny and twisted
and beautiful and incredible it's it's
about rich [ __ ] on a yacht at Sea and
everything goes wrong uh what do you
what do you mean is it a foreign's home
no no it's it's ours and but that this
Reuben Austin no this Reuben oslin this
guy he it is it is a foreign director
but it's incred dude it's incredible uh
and and he's directed by Americans
okay you know what I mean no I don't
you're wrong I'm joking no it's not
funny I'm joking give credit where
credit's due Joe I don't like foreigners
I know never have no but it's incredible
it's about it's about rich it's about
rich constantly yacht and everything
goes around it's out right now you could
just watch it yes and that beautiful
young girl in there R.I.P the girl
that's laying in that right one when she
died she she passed away in real life
like right after this film came out yeah
it was incredible what uh I don't
remember looking at you can look it up
but that really hot chick in the front
yeah she sadly passed away
that's this girl Charlie Dean yeah she
died yeah sad sad what did she die from
bacterial sepsis decades oh no way oh my
god well can you get that after you get
like a staph infection is that what it
is surgery anything yeah yeah Jesus
Christ
but I gotta tell you she [ __ ]
destroys this she's so good in this
movie it's it's like it's [ __ ] it'll
[ __ ] you up how good life is just too
short you never know that's why Joe I
say keep drinking
keep drinking a creep drinking I gotta
stop fighting what's now I gotta get my
[ __ ] together come friends with DJ from
here I'm sorry there's so much [ __ ] to
do babe where could people see you
Andrew Well cheeseburger let's go watch
cheeseburger on Netflix available now as
of January 10th cheeseburger on Netflix
and then Bobby Lee and I are going to be
on tour starting in March but those
dates will be up at badfriendspod.com
watch bad friends watch whiskey Ginger
love you thank you guys
christycomedy.com New Orleans Dallas
Houston we added Florida we got Austin
Vancouver christycomedy.com all the
dates are there some shows are sold out
some aren't so go check it
uh jodarosainfo.com uh for tickets and
Show links oh residency uh of my new
hour I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
happening here in New York City at the
crane theater uh January 25th February
14th and then there's one in March one
in April I'm also going on the road the
Midwest
uh and uh also down south into New
Orleans in that area so just go to my
website get your tickets and everything
there and we'll see you in hell podcast
also my solo tour is currently on pause
because we're back at the three four
year Hiatus on the Impractical Jokers
tour
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
the end of this month we have a warm-up
show in reading and then we're right
into Pittsburgh Camden and Boston it
goes all the way to July right now
there's about 30 40 cities in there
we're coming to the Prudential Center in
Newark the UBS arena in Long Island and
so on and so forth look for your city
Impractical Jokers live.com
foreign
[Music]